Gohan you're still alive we'll fix that
soon enough
kill him full power
go on it can't be
don't go on
oh it's you huh this girl right here
it holds the history where I came from
in it everyone was wiped out by
seventeen and eighteen even go on who
was the last to go if mom hadn't built
that time machine that I and everyone
else in the world would be I can't say
that I approve of building a machine
that can fiddle around with history yeah
oh well no sense in crying over spilled
milk I always say no not this history -
we need to act fast drunks yeah you
understand right I do then good luck
even stronger than the others I'll do
what I can
you have to get out of here I will
destroy whoever interferes
Anglo's
how is he so strong put you out of your
misery
why can't I beat you even against three
of you I am far stronger I must be I
won't let you kill Gohan trunks you came
from the future didn't you
so Bulma was able to finish her time
machine I'm really proud of you trunks
thanks right it's not the time for this
17 and 18 are attacking the city you're
right and this time Gohan go on I'll go
with you to fight this time this time I
won't hold you back
what are you saying you know you're not
allowed to do that trunks if you help
help Gohan here you'll change the course
of history I I know
but I trunks please you have to stop
drunk
trunks is there something you want to
tell me I
if you're here all grown up then the
future is safe isn't it
and so this fight has a real purpose
that's enough for me no you can't go on
trunks it looks like you've made a good
friend
you can't abandon a good friend can you
was really good to see you trunks
go on